If you go into a diner now, or you go into
a diner fifty years ago, the feeling
is the same. It's the experience that
keeps these places going, right. It's what
keeps everybody in here, coming back to
this diner. We had this really cool idea.
We had a way to really differentiate our
stations experience using an app, using
technology. Getting that experience right
and simple is so important for us, oh food is here.
Thank you.
As consumers expectations are changing
because of technology in digital, we said
why should the fueling experience be any
different? We knew what we wanted from a
consumer experience, but what we didn't
know was exactly how to do it, right. So,
when we could focus more on the consumer
experience and IBM was then driving a
technical solution, I felt like IBM was
as committed to our objective as we were.
So, after all this hard work that we put
into this mobile app what did we get out
of it at the end of the day? We have a
platform that our consumers life and
they give us their loyalty. You know the
threats are always changing and we can
trust in the IBM Cloud that when we put
something out there and consumers are
trusting us with their data that it is
protected and it is secure. You guys
scale with us, we don't have to worry
about it. So our servers and
infrastructure and all that stuff that
just works. The highlight moment for me
is just that roll from disbelief to
impressed and when you watch somebody's
face go "oh wow, it worked" it's super cool.
Next time you stop for gas let's do that.
Yeah. And you'll see what I'm talking
about.
So, here we go pay for fuel. You can see
that I'm gonna earn five points a gallon
here.
I'll hit pump 16, I got my credit card
there, it knows I don't want my receipt I
want it to be emailed to me. Then I'll
just hit authorized pump. All right, grab
the nozzle pick our grade, didn't touch
anything else, we're gonna get our points.
Pumps on, fuel. Okay, so where to next?
you